as you well know I am brimming with
masculinity and virility it seeps out my
very poor and in recent years this has
been called toxic by the broader culture
and the powers that they are attempting
to Tamp down my manhood and my just
brutish knuckle dragging kind of
virility so they've got public service
announcements to help men stop being so
damn toxic this one is called Boys Don't
Cry from the organization white ribbon
which exists to make the world free of
gender-based violence kind of vague not
sure exactly what that means this video
is brought to you by good ranchers more
from good ranchers in just a little bit
first though let's get to the PSA let's
learn together folks how to stop being
so masculine
foreign
[Music]
muscles and bring it over here to the
shop
boys can be loving
[Music]
I need you to be brave okay gotta go
boys can be shy
[Music]
boys can be sad
[Music]
why are you crying
Boys Don't Cry honey
be a big boy
boys can be self-conscious
[Music]
boys can be intelligent
[Music]
that escalated very quickly the family
was sitting sort of nice having a nice
time at the table hey Johnny come on
don't cry don't be so sad you got to be
a man and then all of a sudden it's like
a light it turns into a lifetime movie
of some abusive father
[Music]
a hard year on the economy means that
essential practical gifts will be in
high demand this year give the most
essential gift of all America's best
meat and seafood from good Ranchers with
discounts on orders of five boxes or
more you can save on gifts for the whole
family when you give a box of good
ranchers you are giving your friends and
family a true Steakhouse experience with
100 American USDA prime and upper Choice
cuts of beef Chicken and Seafood other
meat delivery companies and even your
local grocery store import lower Quality
Meat from overseas don't give your
friends and family less than America's
best this year not sure what to order
good ranchers now offers gift gift cards
so you can let your friends and family
members choose for themselves or give
the gift of a subscription and you can
inflation proof someone's meat budget
the price never goes up go to go
ranchers.com use code Knowles at
checkout get 35 off your gift that is
goodranches.com code Knowles for 35 off
good ranchers American Meat delivery
keep going Boys Can't Be Afraid
all right
[Music]
boys can't be gentle I don't understand
what the big deal is I mean isn't this
just boys being boys
[Music]
voice can't be weak
[Music]
always can't be to it
[Music]
boys can't be hurt
[Music]
foreign
like shoot somebody or something
[Music]
boys can't be powerless
so you're gonna rape the girl those Boys
Don't Cry
huh the first
thing you've got to ask yourself here is
does this ring true is this what really
happens and I don't think it really does
the thesis of the article is when you
tell boys
and tell them to man up and have some
courage and have some resignation and
show some Bulls keep their problems to
themselves and to to allow suffering to
be a sanctifying experience
but that's going to turn them into
rapist bully killers that but is that
really what happens
what you see in the video is first part
boy wonderful loving sweet gentle good
life then mom tells the boy not to cry
and then his dad starts beating his mom
and he starts punching kids and then he
rapes a woman at the end does that it
reminds me of the the South Park episode
where there are these gnomes that go in
and steal people's boxer shorts
and they say step one steal all of the
underwear step two hmm
step three profit and I think it's that
step two that I don't I don't really buy
here this ad is really an attack on
fortitude it's an attack on virtue you
either seven seven virtues you got the
three theological virtues faith hope and
charity you've got the four cardinal
virtues Justice Temperance prudence and
fortitude and this is an attack on
fortitude and it's an attack on Courage
which is actually the prerequisite for
all of the virtues without which uh the
virtues cannot be put into an effect but
it is good it is good to have strength
and resiliency when when something
doesn't go your way you don't just melt
into a puddle and whine and cry about it
you stand strong maybe you shed a tear
but you wipe it away you keep that stiff
upper lip that is temporary you're being
temporary you're not you're not giving
in to your wildest passions and wailing
and crying all the time it's hopeful
it's not just giving in to the sin of
Despair as always what the libs want to
do is they want to redefine the virtues
as vices and the vices as virtues so
what's the alternative the alternative
is for the boy to just cry and be a
little man be pamby pansy all the time
baby want a bottle
no that's not good either in fact that
very often makes vicious vicious men the
kind who are so consumed with their own
problems real or imagined the ones who
can only think about themselves
it's the ones who believe that the
protection of their feelings are the
most important things in the world it
reminds me of the Marquis De Assad
actually the Marquee decide from whom we
get the word sadism the Marquis decides
philosophy is based on this kind of
radical selfishness and the question
that he asks is
why is your pain any more important than
my pleasure why should I care about
anything that's going on with you when
I'm just focused on my own feelings and
so yeah boys they do cry sometimes but
they try not to they keep it to
themselves they move on they keep a
stiff upper lip they have courage and no
you're not going to turn into a killer
rapist because you can keep your
feelings to yourself no not at all uh
what they say here is we want a better
kind of masculinity but what they really
mean is we we want femininity I'm
sensitive Aubry the the new kind of
masculinity is just femininity and it's
good when women are act like women they
are womanly when they act like women but
when men act like women they're not
called womanly they're called woman-ish
because it's improper for men to behave
like women just as it would be improper
for women to behave like men because the
Sexes are distinct and complementary
okay and what the libs want to do is
just completely invert the order of
reality Boys Don't Cry boys can
sometimes shed one single wistful tear
when they're looking out on the Prairie
you know or sort of watching a baseball
game with their son but you have to kind
of hide it you wipe it away get back in
it Tia and you remain the strong silent
type whatever happened to the strong
silent type that's what Tony Soprano
wanted to know that's what I want to
know too let me know your thoughts in
the comments we'll see you next time
[Music]